let's go to the phones at 6 1 7 8 3 0 47
50 see what's on people's minds well we
will start with our caller from the 4 0
1 area code caller from 4 0 1 who's this
where are you calling from
hey David my name is mark from newport
rhode island how are you hey Mark what's
going on
sure so on your show you've been
expressing your support for modern
monetary theory which posits that rather
than basing expansionary fiscal policy
on some arbitrary measures such as the
deficit to GDP ratio yeah so mark listen
your audio is experiencing a huge
up-and-down
let me just while you maybe figure out
what's going on with your phone I'll say
I've expressed that I have a point of
agreement with mmt which is that not
every dollar of debt is equally
meaningful to the broader economy it
does depend on why we are deficit
spending but if we can better hear you
now go you can go ahead with your
question
oh I'm sorry about that can you hear me
any better now yes I can
oh great so if the the goal of month of
modern monetary theory is to base our
fiscal policy or our only real
constraint on it is inflation my
question to you is if the Federal
Reserve does its job to combat inflation
will the combination of a the increase
in short term rates caused by the Fed
and B the increase in interest rates
caused by the increase in outstanding
government bonds will this increase in
interest rates does that risk offsetting
the growth of the fiscal policy well
you'd have to ask someone who's actually
an adherent to modern monetary theory
and see how they would respond to it so
what again the the primary point that
I've been trying to make over the last
many years is that debt and deficit is
not the objective issue that people
mostly on the right but also on the left
pretend it it is they use it as a
political tool they care about debt and
deficit under some political
circumstances and not under others
depends who's in the Oval Office depends
who's making claims about balancing or
not balancing the deficit and
the point that I make is that we know
that different types of government
spending have different economic
multipliers that are differently
stimulative to the economy so that if
we're talking about a fixed amount of
deficit dollars say a hundred billion
dollars it's not all the same if you
have a hundred billion dollars in
deficit to pay for some social programs
versus a hundred billion dollars in
deficit to give tax cuts to the rich to
your point you'd really have to ask
someone who actually is fully behind mmt
all right and if if mmt says that the
tax cuts mark your audio is down again
to half the volume so i'm gonna let you
go because i've got a lot of people
holding but i really do appreciate the
phone call